à milan ce footballeur de 19 ans a
trouvé ses repères place du dom il
s'émerveille stagiaires à l'as cannes il
y a deux ans encore il avait pour idole
france green card une vedette de milan
dis donc un gosse de 19 ans aux portes
de la gloire mais rassurez-vous la tête
restera bien sur les épaules et ses
potes du centre comme ici mômes aux
séries les joseph qu'il ne retrouvera
toujours avec plaisir
pas mal ce défilé de mannequins aux
dires de ceux qui le côtoient tous les
jours il al'étoffe d'un futur grand mais
pour les autres ce transfert des 30
millions bilan est plutôt surprenant
alors pourquoi les dirigeants une année
sans doute chercher
jours le chantier tout occupant et oui
il en sera de même pour tous ses copains
du centre qui ont désormais un nouveau
club fétiche le milano et les gosses un
peu de calme où je me fâche hockey